rob any time you get to do anything Star
Wars related you're pretty excited and
today we get a really good one it's bb-8
the app enabled droid I zero out now
this was announced for the force Friday
with all the merchandise for Star Wars
and here he is okay yeah you control him
with your ipad iphone 4 iphone 5 and
android um that's pretty freaking cool
so you get like pretty intuitive
movements his head you know it's got the
gyroscope magnet spiel no idea how it
works but it is actually removable that
you can see like the sphere works on its
own and the head is sorry lo de and the
head nap magnet powdered and it's got
rollers on it the noises that you're
hearing right now these adorable are
coming out of the iPad or device you
have which is very cool it's not the
same but it's still very cool so yeah
and then you know you got plenty to do
with this guy so you have also these
kind of a basic quick command so here
you have like a yes there's a little nod
after dorable horrible here's a no I do
not want to be kicked here you have this
is more of a little like freeform like I
ain't no I'm just kind of yeah looking
around here he's winging it on that one
yet um and I just realized there's like
another set of these quick commands
here's one where he will do a square
figure he will patrol on a square that's
pretty cool according to the the chart
this is actually the bb-8 has an
adaptive personality so the attitude
will change based on the interactions
that you have with it if you like
particular buttons or if you make it
freestyle it will actually adapt as you
move on sure here's ah here's another
one you get like a sprint mode which is
pretty cool what every fast he's fat oh
so then you have the other ones here
here's the hot item right here is
message so this is the holographic
communication yes
actually can record a video when you do
a video game help me obi-wan you're my
only hope so then the reversal camera
you line up the droid help me obi-wan
you're my only hope there's dishes and
dirt all over the floor okay bb-8 so I
did voice recognition so I said do it
okay bb-8 it's a trap also you have a
whole you have a whole list of voice
commands and then check out um patrols
it's trolls a lot easier yeah it shows
us that deviates internal temperature is
the currently hundred and four point
nine degrees so he's running hot it's
showing us that he's currently hitting
something Oh silly so you have a little
event log it says like the breeze ahead
life collision form sensor activated I
think he sees Andy as a threat oh and to
top it all off he comes with this sweet
little charger stop them from running
around so much USB hook up to your
computer or you know I'm sure like an
iPhone adapter or anything like that
right and this is out today and it's 150
bucks so it's a great this is gonna be
pretty much on the top of every kid's
Christmas hatzolah wish list and it is
is elusively adorable and cool
yes what about it thanks Ron thank you
for the latest on everything game and
Star Wars related check out GameSpot's
calm
you